[موسيقى]
هذا هو الطيران التكتيكي على بعد أقدام فقط
فوق الصحراء التي تدور حول التلال القريبة
من الحدود السعودية اليمنية مع لانغ
غدًا في اليمن ، على بعد حوالي مائة
ميل شرق العميد البحري ، تحالف الزعيم السعودي الذي
يدعم الحكومة
اليمنية المعترف بها دوليًا
ضد المتمردين الحوثيين المدعومين من إيران
يتعرض كلا الجانبين لانتقادات بسبب
سقوط طائرات أباتشي الحربية في صفوف المدنيين من
أجل الحماية ، فنحن أول
صحفيين غربيين تأخذهم الحكومة السعودية
إلى اليمن ، ووعدوا
بالشفافية
بأننا نسافر عالياً في الجبال
ونزور الخطوط الأمامية للحكومة اليمنية
ونبقى منخفضًا هنا لأننا  لقد
تم إخبار الحوثيين في أسفل الوادي
ربما أوديسيوس ولقاء ضحايا هذه
الزيارة الحربية التي استمرت ثلاث سنوات مع الأطفال
الجنود في إعادة التأهيل الذين يعانون من اضطراب ما بعد الصدمة ،
استجوب قادة اليمن لقد كنت
وضعًا هنا في عدن ، ما الحقيقة التي
قالها لي رئيس الوزراء  يفعلون
الآن أنهم يطبعون أموالهم الخاصة
بمساعدة إيران و Questi  على
الأشخاص حول نفس هؤلاء القادة الذين
قابلتهم رئيس الوزراء أمس في
مكتبه على الجانب الآخر من المدينة ،
مما جعلني أفعلهم دائمًا ما أقوم به مرتين ،
إنه كاذب ما نراه هنا
طابعة ثلاثية الأبعاد تستخدم
أيادي اصطناعية  ولقاء اليمنيين الذين
على الرغم من كل شيء لا يزال لديهم أمل ،
نريد التعليم ، فنحن نريد الحصول على وظائف
فهم الحرب هنا مع
كل شخص يمر بها
يشبه إلى حد ما تقشير طبقة البصل بعد طبقة
نريد تقشير تلك الطبقات من
أجل الكشف عن الجدار والصراع  للبقاء على
قيد الحياة ، يقول إن الحافر يستخدم هذه
الصورة له وهو يأخذ ابنه
ليدفن ليقول إن البعض قُتل
في غارة جوية للتحالف يقول إن هذا
لم يكن صحيحًا ، فهناك الكثير من الأصوات
، وقد سمع القليل جدًا من
قبل  NIC روبرتسون سي إن إن اليمن ترى
بلدة صغيرة هنا يوجد حوثيون في
هذه المدينة